la défilé a suffi dimanche et christian
lacroix l'arlésien est devenu la
nouvelle coqueluche du tout-paris ex
styliste de chez patou il est débauché
par la financière agache il y a six mois
pour créer une nouvelle maison de haute
couture 50 millions de francs sont
investis sur son nom que si on la croit
christian dior céline depuis peu le
groupe agache possède désormais trois
griffes de haute couture
si on la croit c'est la mode très
original très actuel dior l'élégance
raffinée très sophistiqué céline le
style traditionnel bon chic bon genre
qui revient à la mode est donc cette
stratégie consiste à offrir une palette
complète de produits à la clientèle et à
avoir par rapport aux distributeurs
mondiaux
un impact est une force beaucoup plus
grande parce que nous avons trois
marques complémentaires plutôt qu'une
seule ce sont désormais les hommes
d'affaires les financiers qui
investissent dans le luxe il faut
croître pas trop vite si on ne veut pas
disparaître la clientèle se ferra
exigeante de grands groupes doivent se
constituer
carlo de benedetti rachète les parfums
yves saint laurent
réguillon s'associe à karl lagerfeld
derrière christian dior le groupe à
gages c'est aussi férinel conforama peau
douce 18 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
mais le mariage le plus réussi celui de
huit ans et deux mois tu n 6 qui avec
les bagages les cognacs nos cils et
champagne veuve clicquot les parfums
givenchy dior et guerlain réalise près
de 2 milliards de bénéfice net
en 1987 l'enjeu est internationale la
grande question des temps modernes c'est
celle de pouvoir continuer à faire de la
qualité tout en résolvant le problème de
la quantité
il faut un apport logistique importante
exprimées en termes de moyens de moyens
financiers donc d'industrie de lot c'est
pour ça qu'on parle d'industrie de
l'autre quand on parle maintenant
d'industrie de création l'âge d'or où il
suffisait d'avoir un nom pour faire
fortune est révolu il faut prendre des
risques se diversifier la création ne va
plus en marketing pour lancer poison du
parfum dior
le groupe 8 on a dépensé 200 millions de
francs mais quelques maisons familiales
nba ne veulent pas être racheté certains
mariages sont même raté celui entre la
maison grès et le groupe bernard tapie
par exemple la sphère est actuellement
devant les tribunaux
il n'est pas question pour madame grès
de faire du prêt-à-porter